all the time you have to to dream
bigger and and further you know and not
just look on the the specific thing um i
think bring the best people and the
great talents that can handle
these things
for you and help you to take this step
back look on the big picture and try to
to navigate this ship in the best way
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet gal
rotman the co-founder and ceo of sensei
which is on a mission to drive people
around the world to become more active
balanced and healthy as a marathon
runner by himself and a major rank from
the idea of special forces he is
motivated by combining his biggest
passion physical activities and deep
technology
holds the bsc in physics and economics
one out of two in the whole year and
prior to since he was involved in
closing multi-million dollar deals in
fortune 500 companies
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
for joining me
hey mikhail thank you for having me i'm
uh i'm a big fan of the this show so i'm
so happy to be here
i i thank you very very much and i'm a
huge fan of the problem that you're
solving and we're talking today about
movements computer vision and the way we
are going to be rethinking of precision
when it comes to to sports and and
exercises and and obviously there's a
bunch of applications for the technology
that you're developing one of which i
can already you know see for myself as
i'm trying to train with a trainer on
zoom which doesn't work but being able
to give me actual pointers i think
that's going to be really fascinating so
god tell me a little bit about yourself
and the formation of scentsy yeah
so
by myself you know i'm i'm i'm basically
kind of of this scentsy when when you
look on on myself back back back then
because
actually i i'm by myself evolving two
things com combine two things big
passion to sports and and technology by
myself through all my uh
my childhood till today um
i played i used to to play basketball
many years and then i moved to running i
just ran a few marathons
and wow
till today
and and the other guy is the one that
loved to you know to hang out with
friends and and and love the the tech
world where where i um
where studied
physics and economics and then started
my world in the in the tech world where
i
took positions in you know development
and sales and so on so
and that's what actually lead me to to
scentsy and one also one one more thing
that was important in this journey it
was my uh background in the idf i served
like kind of like the typical
typical founder in israel but with a
a short twist i was in the special
forces for five years so
that's another place that i have able to
to combine this my two passions and
actually all of that lead me to to start
at scentsy
awesome so with any great story it
starts with a huge huge problem what is
the huge problem that scentsy is coming
in to solve
so so basically we are looking about
you know how people keep about their
movement or keep about their health in
these days
and when i'm saying these days i'm i'm
cheering about
you know we we all suffer from the
kaveed during the last two years and and
we experienced a huge transformation
from how people used to keep about their
health
and actually the
awareness of people about their health
and people today want to be able to do
on one hand a regular regular things in
life like you know
keep the regular life and be healthy and
on the other side be
better athletes and so on and actually
things that can keep about their
physical conditions
um
and
until the the kovid started it was very
obvious if you either go to the gym or
either go to your doctor or physicians
or personal trainer or you know you know
whatever it can be
and
and we believe
and the times has changed
you know that today the people want to
have to keep about the health in a
regular basis
and
we believe that the future everything
you will do um
you want to get get tracked and and with
our technology and the ability you know
to to interact with people in real time
and help people to achieve their goals
in real time this is the new the new
world actually and the new the new way
um
to achieve physical goals
right so
the question stems because we've seen
companies like peloton and lululemon and
and countless of of organizations that
are that are offering these remote
services for
for for exercises why aren't we getting
this precision technology until now what
what is missing from the world because
it's obviously such a huge need yeah so
so first of all that that's that's
definitely a huge need and we experience
that in every day like when when we talk
with people when i talk with my friends
with my colleagues when i'm when i meet
people it's it's a huge need need that
everybody suffer from it and i think
there are some market conditions
uh that gathered together these days
that can actually
push this solution forward one is the
is the is the awareness and awareness
started with companies like as you
mentioned peloton lululemon temple some
other companies that started with this
um
idea of bringing sports fitness wellness
to people home by expensive hardware
devices and they actually was where they
pioneered and and the time you know uh
move forward and then the technology um
is mature and mature all the time and
now we are able to take all this
hardware component into our small device
which is the mobile phone and now we can
add sensi can implement this technology
on the mobile phone to interact with the
people um not with these expensive or
immobile devices but with the tool that
everybody has
and i think both of that things the the
market uh the market awareness and and
on the other side the technology matures
matureness it's that both of them lead
us to
to be able to to bring this solution
nowadays to the table beautiful so so
you have the solution you're working you
know on deep technology with a huge pain
point that you know millions of people
around the world are using but now what
so you know as the ceo of this ship
how are you strategically thinking
through the potential of censor and
you've already
impacted quite quite a few people from
what i saw right
yeah so actually today we are
impacting a daily basis more than 350
000 people wow and this number is
growing you know um daily i hope
and we we do all the effort that it will
grow uh daily uh and we have actually
the you know the honor to help people in
in a real things in their life because
people actually use our products to get
the better themselves and take better
about their physical conditions and
if if
if we try to see
how how to increase this number or maybe
in a better view how to help more people
uh to improve and get better health
conditions
um
we are trying to bring um solutions and
new features that actually people want
and you know as a as a consumer company
we are trying to discuss with our
customers and talk with them in a daily
basis so we can actually learn what what
the needs and what the pains of our
existing users and and we do our efforts
in actually
to solve these
kind of small
pains but but that that the things that
can
build and improve the product day after
day
and so if you're looking at the vision
of scentsy beyond the technology and
beyond the beyond the precision
what is sort of the grand vision of this
company as you're seeing in the next few
years
yeah so we have we have actually a very
clear vision you know one of my uh one
of my job is to put this very clear
vision uh
to everybody actually uh and this north
star and this actually help people to
live a better and healthier life
it sounds like okay a bombastic one and
very big but we believe that if we help
people day after day to get a better
condition about their
health and wellness and actually
make more people more healthier and more
more in shape and this is our vision
and we believe that
taking
actually different use cases as you
started with it can be in the fitness
world it can be in the elderly world it
can be in a in just in the wellness
sector
to build these specific use cases and
specific products to every uh specific
audience this is this is what we are
aiming for
and so if you had to think with me
through the challenges
of of entering a space like this you
know what what are some of the greatest
challenges that that a company like
sensei you know gets and then how do you
as a ct a ceo you know tackle those
challenges
yeah so i'm smiling because you know the
challenges are so so many
um
and and i really like this question
because then you need to look on our
yourself and understand what really um
really is important to to solve so i
think the main challenge here is the uh
is
is to get into space that were used to
to
to be in one
one place or one situation that people
used to i don't know
get their personal trainer or physician
or no matter what and then started to
get to use to the idea that they can get
orders or
or plans from
from a technology based platform of
course our technology is based on
professional physicians and trainers and
and not by ourselves but this is one one
of the biggest challenges and i think
the second challenge is
how to
how to you know the um
to take all the advantages of the big
companies and the companies that you do
mention and and put it into this
uh daily tool like your mobile phone and
and
and to take it to the market
um and the last one if if i can share i
think it's the uh like always the the
distribution and this is one of the
things that we are putting a lot of
effort to find the best distribution
channels and we have some great ideas uh
ahead
um yeah i think that that summer is the
main challenges
let's talk a little bit about consumer
behavior and the shift of consumer
behavior and the experience here
you know with sensi and with with the
way that now consumers are going to be
able to get this precision
feedback from software from trainers etc
how do you believe
consumer behavior around exercise will
shift
and what will shift over time in terms
of you know the average consumers of
this
yeah um so
so we we
we actually see this phenomenon in a
daily basis um
if i'm taking you know one and a half
years ago
before the kovit it was like science
fiction right people said why why should
i need that it's it's not it's not make
sense
but today world when when everything
move remotely your job is remotely your
interviews are remotely your
fundraising processes remotely so people
get used to it and it's like okay this
is the new norm and i think that's
you you know you sometimes have to
has to have some luck so we we were in
the in the right side in this in this
case
and
and people used to get
orders or communicate with people not
just in the regular way but um um thanks
to the technology so
i think that's that's one side and the
second and the second aspect of that
we see that people want to get
um
itself of um kind of recognition about
what they did and recognition can be you
know some support not just like okay
your squad is 90 19 and not 80
people more care about wow great you did
you did it just on time while you're
getting improving and and why why once
people get this
um
support and ongoing support this is this
is the key
and
um yeah
so it sounds like you're bringing a lot
of the gamification channels you know
that are used to to keep people engaged
with the the short feedback loops the
precise the precision matrix of how they
can improve
the the comfort of knowing that
somebody's watching you know i think i'm
i'm
i'm sort of equating it to the
experience in the gym if i'm in a group
session and all of a sudden i'm training
and then when i see the trainer going
away from me i sort of give out i give i
give way and i don't do the exercise too
much but then when the trainer is coming
close to me and i know that they're
going to look at me all of a sudden i'm
pumping the weights because i want to
get that recognition right
yeah so so so you're totally right you
can we we love to think about that the
the same thing that wearables did to the
market you know everybody like crazy
about complete my circle in the in the
apple watch for example so we believe
that
in the uh
in the in the next few years like
everything you do you want to get
recognized about that because if you
didn't do that and we you didn't measure
that it doesn't count exactly it doesn't
experience with your personal trainer so
we believe the future will be like when
you do the movement
someone can
provide you feedback about that and can
keep that data and can can help you
improve session after session and and
that's the key actually
i know i think that it's going to be
interesting to to see
you know a new generation of trainees
now that are going to be getting this
precision feedback online
and you know truly the democratization
of training and and being able to really
understand what you're doing right what
you're doing wrong you know i think that
if you go on on youtube there's you know
thousands of videos on how to do a
proper squat and people still
you know when they do it i know for
myself i still ask trainers every day to
look at me from the side and tell me how
i'm doing and and you know this is a
just a huge pain point that you're
solving and i think that it's going to
be interesting to look at a generation
of trainees and see how they are now
rethinking about you know both their
healthy lifestyles but also the
understandings of what they're doing gal
from your personal perspective as a ceo
you know how how are you you know in
terms of you know work taking something
that you're so excited about marathon
runner you know lots of exercise and now
managing a company in the same domain
and looking at it not just from the
experiential side but now also from the
business side but what is that process
like for you
yeah so
so
that's a great question right because
some of the things that you want to to
do as as a user as a potential user and
and that's like let's do that like that
because i want to experience the product
like that and so on but on the other
side you need to take decisions based on
what is good to the company and uh in
the strategy level and high level and so
on so that's that's actually a good a
great question and and i think that
i'm trying to take myself a bit from
this
beat and bytes of you know the
specific experience on how the squat it
is for from your example and so on and
to to look on it on an um in a bigger
perspective
and and actually one of the things that
i learned from this journey so far is
like
all the time you have to to dream
bigger and and further you know and not
just look on the the specific thing um i
think bring the best people and the
great talents that can handle
these things
for you and help you to take this step
back look on the big picture and try to
to navigate this ship in the best way i
think that that's one of the practical
tools that i'm trying to do um yeah and
i'm trying to improve you know every day
incredible incredible god i really want
to thank you for these 20 minutes and
and i love these examples of
technologies that are coming and they're
completely changing the way that the
weak consumers are experiencing products
and i think that what's really
interesting here also is that you know
that it's a deep technology company it's
a computer vision based company that you
know is acting more in the background
and you know a lot of times the the the
consumers may not even realize that
there is this technology that is running
behind the feedback that they're getting
now from their next you know whatever
peloton experience or whatever companies
maybe at the end using scentsy and and i
just think that that is so cool and the
ripple effect of the impact that you're
having is just tremendous if you had to
to think of a few words that would
describe you and
what what few words would those be
yeah
um so i think
first is a
it's it's kind of a team player or
people person
uh it's one of the things that i learned
from the from the army you know the the
team is everything like uh it's the most
important thing my co-found founders are
from my team
so
you know just just a team player and and
surround yourself with great people and
and stick everybody together to to the
same mission i think that that's the
first one
um the second one i think is kind of you
know a hustler or pusher or or don't
stop
even if you see hard things and we
talked a bit about these challenges and
so on so never give up and and
continue pushing
very hard
and
and maybe the third one is the is kind
of the opposite for that is that is to
still keep be optimistic
uh with this uh you know um spirit of
nonsense like
take the the doer perspective and
look about things and say okay how we
can make it and not look on the channels
but look how we can solve things so i
think this is the three of the things
that i'm trying to to to behind them to
stand behind them and and communicate to
the team
thank you for the great impact that
you're having on the world and society a
big ripple effect that is going to make
a lot of impact and with very cool
technology behind it so thank you very
much best of luck with scentsy and stay
safe and stay healthy
mikhail thank you very much it was a
pleasure thank you
[Music]
you